i got a chance to hang out with uh rick
rubin thanks to you he's a friend of
yours and you made the connection that
was a huge gift to my
spirit i guess he's a truly truly
special human being and
the there's a lot i could say about why
he's a special human being i'd love to
learn how you met him but i should also
just mention on the pubmed thing
it was so interesting talking to him
about music
and uh both on the podcast and privately
and just listening to music together
because
when you mention a song
he does this thing where he like closes
his eyes
and he finds that song in the album that
we're talking about and he steps through
the album you could see the brain like
stepping through individual songs to
find that song in the album and there's
that kind of look up process and then he
puts himself mentally in that space of
like
okay this is uh you know
whatever the album is and not just the
ones he produced but
all he's an encyclopedia of of music and
it's so interesting
it also uh the thing i really
love about this something like a
calmness that radiates from him that's
okay to close your eyes and place
yourself in in the in the place where
that album was recorded
in the feeling of that album
and like that that silence let's go
there let's go there together let's look
at alice in wonderland and we'll go
there together you do a good rick rubin
minus the beard minus the beard his
beard is epic right you can't fake a
beard like that you know how'd you guys
meet
yeah well rick i'm very blessed to
consider a close friend um rick and i
got introduced through a common friend
during the pandemic and we started doing
some face time together and just talking
about things related to science and
health and i i'm not a musician i have
no musical ability or talent i have a
good ability to memorize lyrics and i
love lyrics and i love poetry so i asked
him a lot of questions about musicians
that i happen to love that he's worked
with and knows and so he would give me
stories about musicians and i would talk
to him about
health and then eventually we formed a
friendship where we would talk about any
number of different topics in life
and then we started spending time
together in person uh when he was in
town or nearby
and
as you now know uh you know rick
in addition to all his incredible
accomplishments has an incredible
understanding
of
how to
get the brain and body into state right
and as you pointed out he's willing to
do the things that allow him to help
these incredible artists get into the
best state to do their craft
and so if he needs to sit there and be
quiet with his eyes closed for a minute
or two and or more
he'll do that
he has routines to allow himself to get
into state and it's really inspired me
to think about
states of mind as something that you
know we'd all love to just just flip the
switch and say we're focused or we're
creative but um to actually
ratchet through the the challenging
steps in order to do that and to figure
out what one needs to do on a regular
basis to get into a proper state it's
not just going to come from a cup of
coffee
a you know
a lamp of a particular wavelength or
something it's going to be those things
but it's also going to be really
teaching oneself how to get into proper
state yeah you did an episode on
hypnosis do you think it's a kind of
self-hypnosis
yes i do um because hypnosis is a
con you limit the context you're very
alert
and you're very calm
and um he has a number of these
different practices and so we would talk
about those and then we also have
enjoyed a lot of discussions about deep
neuroscience in fact i introduced rick
to a friend of mine who's a neurosurgeon
and neuroscientist and they've become
friendly you know rick is one of these
people that he sort of defies
um incredibly kind incredibly private
person too so you know i'm being
respectful of that but um and then of
course uh he's a fan of your podcast and
so when i learned that i i it just made
natural sense to introduce you and i
know he really enjoyed meeting you and
we talk about you a lot and of course in
a positive light you know i think his
dedication to
getting into these states of mind and
his willingness to do that has
completely transformed my routines
around life like for instance before
doing a very long podcast recording the
solo ones which often take me several
hours or more six hours to record
sometimes more sometimes less i realize
that there's a certain brain state
associated with that so i have to really
limit the kind of interactions i have
for the two hours before i actually walk
and talk out loud
through my neighborhood people think i'm
crazy but i live in a neighborhood where
there are a lot of crazy
creatives anyway saying you're not crazy
well um at least not uh
institutionally defined as crazy yet but
um you know getting into state of mind
is something that we'd all just imagine
we flip the switch but rick really
convinced me you have to do the work to
do the work
can you maybe uh
linger on that lucid day a little bit
more your process of how you get in that
space that's really interesting as i i
have to admit
i do everything last minute before
podcast i don't know
uh like there's a lot of anxiety because
like whatever if i have to pack if i
have to set up stuff
you were luckily a few minutes you
showed up a few minutes later which for
an academic is right on right on time
but the stress is immense
and uh
on top of that you look at like a
situation with rick rubin
he's out i had to set up microphones in
front of him
and just that stress the anxiety he
knows a lot about microphones what did
he say which i really loved he's like
how close
do you like
the microphone to be
it's like that's a very rick rubin kind
of thing right that the details really
matter yeah the details really matter
right down to
your relationship to the microphone
right yeah distance and whether or not
it brings out the timbre in your voice
but of course that's what he does he
produces music but he also said like you
know he is the professional
he said
how close do you like it to be and he
said it with the gentleness where i had
like an existential crisis where i don't
i don't know i
he gave me so much like
wow like he made me feel like an artist
like that the microphone uh distance is
a decision you're supposed to make well
i have to say and this has actually come
up in some of our conversations about
you i mean you are you are an artist and
actually joe rogan
once i heard him talking about
podcasting and the fact that he's always
trying to get better at it you know and
he described podcasting in one moment as
an art right and it is it's a certain
medium of communication and there's a
cadence and a rhythm that um when it's
working it really can facilitate the
transfer of information when it's not it
doesn't i mean obviously joe just being
himself has tapped into that cadence
that allows and it's made so many people
excited to hear him talk well in his
case and in general i think part of the
art
is uh refusing the world as you get a
bigger audience
change who you are there's one quote
that i've seen out there where he says
you know i'm like the talking about
himself he says you know i'm like the
fish that got through the net there's no
stage version of me right how he is
in person is how he is uh you know out
in the world and of course there's
nuance to his life right and his
different um relationships of course but
it's true i mean we've had the you know
the great fortune of spending time with
him out away from the microphones so to
speak
joe is joe
you